In just 3 easy steps, you'll be able to flash
freeze a bottle of water just by touching
it.
Next you'll learn how to to freeze flowing
water, the instant it's poured from the bottle.
And your training will be complete when you
can eliminate the bottle altogether.
Now this might seem slightly supernatural,
but you don't have to be a master to do it.
In this project, we're discovering the secrets
to Ice-bending - in real life.
For this project, we'll be using these bottles
of purified water.
I've got the 16.9 ounce bottles, and they've
never been opened, so the water is extremely
pure.
Now the secret to instant ice is just about
as simple as placing your bottles in the freezer.
I let these ones sit for 2 hours and 45 minutes
exactly, and here you can see the water is
still liquid, but it's actually cooled down
to a temperature well below freezing.
All it takes from this point is a sharp jolt
to the bottle, and you can see the water flash
freezes to ice right in the palm of your hand.
How cool is that?
You can also start the reaction by using an
ice crystal, like one these ice cubes.
Just carefully remove the cap from the bottle,
and pour the water directly onto the ice.
The water immediately beings to crystalize,
giving you the power to create your own instant
ice sculptures.
The end result is a slush that has the consistency
of a watery snowball .. which, of course,
is 100% edible, and refreshingly delicious.
Now try pouring your super-cooled water into
a clean glass, and drop a bit of ice right
in the center.
You'll see the ice crystal beings to grow
until it fills the glass completely.
That's perfectly chilled for a hot summers
day.
Alright, let's finish up by dipping just the
tip of an ice cube in to see what happens.
Within a couple of seconds it's frozen in
place, and the entire cup is solid.
Well, now you know the secret to pouring yourself
some instant ice, and making water freeze
on command.
Now, if you'd like to see more of the technical
details, check out my other video with tips,
tricks, and things to watch out for when making
Instant Ice.
That's it for now.
If you liked this project, perhaps you'll
like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com